in this segment we will discuss a little
bit the Union bound and then discuss a
counterpart which is known as the
bonferroni inequality let us start with
a story suppose that we have a number of
students in some class and we have a set
of students that are smart let's call
that set a one so this is the set of
smart students and we have a set of
students that are beautiful
and let's call that set a two so a two
is the set of beautiful students if I
tell you that the set of smart students
is small and the set of beautiful
students are small then you can probably
conclude that there are very few
students that are either smart or
beautiful what does this have to do with
probability well when we say very few
are smart we might mean that if I pick a
student at random there's only a small
probability that they pick a smart
student and similarly for beautiful
students can we make this statement more
precise indeed we can we have the Union
bound that tells us that the probability
that I pick a student that is either
smart or beautiful is less than or equal
to the probability of picking a smart
student plus the probability of picking
a beautiful student so if this
probability is small and that
probability is small then this
probability will also be small which
means that there is only a small number
of students that are either smart or
beautiful now let us try to turn this
statement around its head suppose that
most of the students are smart and most
of the students are beautiful so in this
case I'm telling you that this sets a 1
and a 2 are big
now if the set a1 is big then it means
that this set here the complement of a1
is a small set and if I tell you that
the set a2 is big then it means that
this set here which is a complement of
a2 is also small so everything outside
here is a small set which means that
whatever is left which is the
intersection of a1 and a2 should be a
big set so we should be able to conclude
that in this case most of the students
belong to the intersection so they're
both smart and beautiful how can we turn
this into a mathematical statement it's
the following inequality that we will
prove shortly but what it says is that
the probability of the intersection is
larger than or equal to something and if
this probability is close to 1 which
says that most of the students are smart
and this probability is close to 1 which
says that more students are beautiful
then this difference here is going to be
close to 1 plus 1 minus 1 which is 1
therefore the probability of the
intersection is going to be larger than
or equal to some number that's close to
1 so this one will also be close to 1
which is the conclusion that indeed most
students fall in this intersection and
they're both smart and beautiful so what
we will do next will be to derive this
inequality and actually generalize it so
here is the relation that we wish to
establish we want to show that the
probability of a certain event is bigger
than something how do we show that one
way is to show that
the probability of the complement of
this event namely this event here we
want to show that this event has small
probability now what is this event here
we can use the Morgan's laws which tell
us that this event is the same as this
one that is the complement of an
intersection is the union of the
complements since these two sets or
events are identical it means that their
probabilities will also be equal and
next we will use the Union bound to
write this probability as being less
than or equal to the sum of the
probabilities of the two events whose
Union we are taking now we're getting
close except that here we have
complements all over whereas up here we
do not have any complements what can we
do well the probability of a complement
of an event is the same as one minus the
probability of that event and we do the
same thing for the terms that we have
here this probability here is equal to
one minus the probability of a1 and this
probability here is equal to one minus
the probability of a2 and now if we take
this inequality cancel this term with
that term and then move terms around
what we have exactly is exactly this
relation that we wanted to prove it
turns out that this inequality has a
generalization to the case where we take
the intersection of n events and this
has again the same intuitive content
suppose that each one of these events a
1 up to a
is almost certain to occur that is it
has a probability close to 1 in that
case this term will be close to n we
subtract n minus 1 so this term on the
right hand side will be close to 1
therefore the probability of the
intersection will be larger than or
equal to something that's close to 1 so
this is big essentially what it's saying
is that we have big sets and we take
their intersection then that
intersection will also be big in terms
of having large probability how do we
prove this relation exactly the same way
as it was proved for the case of two
sets namely instead of looking at this
event we look at the complement of this
event and we use the Morgan's laws to
write this complement as the union of
the complements these two are the same
sets or events so they have the same
probability and then we use the Union
bound to write this as being less than
or equal to the probabilities of all
those sets now this is equal to 1 minus
the probability of the intersection this
side here is equal to 1 minus the
probability of a1 this is one term we
get n such terms the last one being 1
minus the probability of a n and we
still have an inequality going this way
we collect those ones that we have here
there's n of them and 1 here so we're
left with n minus 1 terms that are equal
to 1 and this gives rise to this term we
have
all the probabilities of the various
events that appear with the same sign
this gives rise to this term and finally
this term here will correspond to that
term namely if we start with this
inequality and just rearrange a few
terms we obtain this inequality up here
so these bonferroni inequalities are a
nice illustration of how one can combine
the Morgan law set theoretic operations
and the Union bound in order to obtain
some interesting relations between
probabilities